what up gamers it's five nights at
Freddy's x everyone's favourite video
game I don't like this series I think
it's obnoxious it has a lot of jump
scares then yes it startles you in the
beginning but after a while it gets a
bit repetitive but it's out for VR as
you can tell by my headset and it
actually looks pretty legit so I'm
really really curious to see what this
is all about but without the further
gaming ado let's freaking into it the
gaming alright let's do it the gaming
let's make a gaming everyone morning I'm
a gamer I music okay let's go hey the
freddy fazbear's virtual experience your
entertainment is excited to join the
digital age and what better way to do
that than with an edge of your seat
virtual reality experience we know that
fazbear entertainment has developed
something of a bad reputation over the
last few decades and while it's true
that some stories associated with our
name were loosely based on actual events
jority of them were occasions from the
mind of a complete lunatic lawsuit spin
right but we ourselves ha ha ha that's
why we have recreated many of these
completely fictitious scenarios that
you've been fed over the last several
years into a hilarious VR game I can
finally move past these childish ghost
stories and develop a new relationship
with you as well as your kids don't
forget the merger if ik for birthdays so
sit back and enjoy a few scares so is
this gonna be just like finance Freddy's
video artist did you agree to be sued
wavered
you acknowledge that fazbear
entertainment is not responsible for
accidental digital consciousness
transference real-world manifestations
of digital characters nightmares night
terrors night sweats what what I just
shine up for night terror and night
width
welcome to the Freddy fazbear's virtual
experience tomorrow we use the console
or get the view to navigate the menu and
pick one of the frightening experiences
available by completing these scenarios
more will become available you'll see
plenty of familiar faces and some new
ones as well so stay a while and have a
good time and remember despite the
temporary horror you may experience this
is a completely controlled environment
and you aren't in any real danger so
it's it's fine as Freddy's VR that I
just spent five minutes to play five
nights at Freddy's VR okay this is
pretty oh god this is scary
Oh God hello hello hello hello hello hi
ro oh wow shut up
the stakes are real now Eve's a mr.
cupcake you'll be my friend you'll sit
right here
god damn it are you protecting me are we
missing any lore of curse now roulette
mustn't on the run can you shut your
freaking pipe or Oh anybody go
what about he go what a body going what
a barnacles oh god what is that they're
closed oh god they're all that I think I
should probably oh my god he was right
there
where's them chicken chicken is still
there we're fine let's suck at the skin
flick I know I've never been good at
these that's why I hate it's literally
outside go away go away
no one likes bunnies anyway god it's so
laggy dude Oh God
does that mean he's gear okay he's
coming
okay okay good he's still there
go away please huh I hate this job
why did I ever take this job I'm okay we
can open
okay we can open no way get out of my
house okay I think it look yeah yeah he
left okay so now okay we're fine this is
great fact you two going pretty good
okay okay I'm starting to know it's
actually easier to switching cameras
especially without the cupcake guy
so where did bunny go where is that
coming from
I have no power I hate this stupid game
why are they scare me I wasn't even
scared cupcake I trusted you god dammit
it's fine it happens to the best of us I
wasn't even scared
it's called Swedish kungfu and it's it's
all about whaling your hands around your
face to make sure that you're safe okay
it's completely normal
it's completely safe and it's it's been
approved by people everywhere please for
the love of God don't make the guy
that's all like you suck oh he's close
already dude do something do something
where is everyone
there's bunny okay I knew the hell is
that ugly cheap summertime is it's 1:00
a.m. I gotta make this six right okay
without it's possible the light thing is
like really effective does he forget
that you're surrounded
what does that mean
[Music]
hey Barney boy hey
where is she
what does that mean go okay are you
trading all my energy go away okay this
okay
alright we're fine and she's gone we can
go it's easy
what does that mean what does that mean
I don't know English help
[Music]
okay okay and I can't get it to party
all right I think we're doing okay
I think we are doing okay all right I do
hear someone walking I don't know if I
should look it's fine I have plenty
power left just keeping it real at this
point I definitely heard someone
yes this sucker my Swedish meatballs
up up up up yeah okay I did it I did
something in my life I completed the
easiest level and I feel incredibly
proud of myself
game 1 claim your price oh it better be
a good price
[Music]
[Applause]
I gave math to time show time
let's go let's go it at school no thanks
don't want anything they become more
active mr. cupcake I don't know that's
really sad don't care you cupcake virgin
I will look there to like in the dining
ok I'm not in dangerous trick
pirate Cove this this one oh yeah
foxy come along oh no mr. pilot is
waking ah look son of a snake these
snakes are everywhere so it's safe now
right yeah
no [ __ ] you sucker my meatball go away
no one like a chicken a vegetarian a
very good sea bream what the bayonet
guys Jemile but far go low
get away from my house
but bootiful a mr. I don't like you
alright have you gone he's gone and he's
gone go away
it's fine it's fine I'm keeping my eyes
on
doctors like dork that is total bullcrap
I was totally Oh squeeze my neck my neck
muscles we're ready to explosion all
right this time I keep my eyes shut your
freakin pipe I was so close to clicking
on it so bullcrap never know what
they're gonna do they always come with
your booty to come out
[Music]
we make music at this hour that you are
you sexy something I would bring no
shame like I'm not even buried she kept
thinking free I don't even find birds
that attractive but she guides she just
brings some there you are you snake oh
she can move she gets on the move she
get them to move she got chica
cha-cha-cha all right all right
I'm a fortune
the door is closed
30 30 30 30 30 30 close up Thank You Man
- the human stopped listening your eyes
is about to beat this oh you hit the
door leave the door you got me
you tell me gingka coming
djenka are you doing you want to come to
my house with the land
Ino Gingka this is my house and no one
can senator all right okay sorry sorry I
forgot all right you're cool right all
right we're doing pretty good she got
there she got here
chica in my chair chica in my head
chica ate my pan chica has a pair of I
like um I love them a lack of my love
hey chica you wanna come to my house so
bad
I am sorry chica you cannot come to my
house why because I do not like you
check the pirate Cove hey you want to
come to my house sorry
we can say no disguise' thank you I'm
telling it dude
Oh God
a [ __ ] I want to come to my house
hell yeah I did it again I'm so good at
games yeah that's me
open gift I'm hey I don't mean to eat it
I want to drink it obviously dumb game
nine three let's go let's go bro once
you know how to play the game like I'm
really good at video games people don't
understand I'm a pro gamer this is what
I do so now I'm Freddie Patek how much
am I paid by the way
is it like a Jake Paul name friendship
for the fun and fame oh god I can't see
anything
I lost tracking oh look at you big boy
alright I got to be ready on the door
here I'm done all right that was finite
siffredi vr hope you guys enjoyed smash
like subscribe if you want more and I
see you guys next time bye bye what you
never played two four simulator you know
it's fun right I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but give it a try and then
you can tell me if it's good or not not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]